ladies and gentlemen please can I have
your attention we finish counting the
votes and as such are ready to declare
the result with the candidates like to
join me on the stage
[Music]
okay i the undersigned being the deputy
acting returned an officer at the
election held on Thursday the 8th of
June to 17 to hereby give notice that
the number of votes cast for each
candidate of the election is as follows
Baker Steve the Green Party
Jones
Nigel Graham the Conservative Party
candidate eighteen thousand seven
hundred and forty seven votes matters
Justin peers Richard Labour Party thirty
thousand one hundred and thirty-seven
bags the num matters Justin P as Richard
Labour Party thirty thousand one hundred
and thirty seven the number of ballot
papers rejected was as follows want of
official Mark zero voting for more
candidates than the voter was entitled
to twenty right single mark by which the
voter could be identified one being
unmarked or wholly void from certainty
48 total rejected votes sixty-nine am i
hereby declare that matters
Justin P as Richard has been duly
elected as the Member of Parliament for
Ellesmere Port and nestin constituency
[Applause]
I will now invite any candidate who
wishes to address the audience to step
forward before I then address the
hard-working staff at the end of the
evening thank you
all of this first of all electronic
monitoring staff do look so hard tonight
and throughout there's a very very long
day for everyone
and with what extremely well we've got
it and finishing record time also like
to thank completed our Alpha Team course
life of the wives and family for their
support and patience and during
an election to cool but it wasn't like
particulate about my abilities I have so
far not that just shown you don't have
to accept business as usual with you
other people that they respond and
fantastic response before Lester tonight
so I've been up about six weeks ago the
Prime Minister cause this election for
what I think with very narrow party
political reasons she is now been well
and truly found out and this is a tale
of two elections it's the one chosen no
one's in which was all about leaders you
can practice it and the election that
people wanted on a debate on are crude
wing public services on the masses and
fans in our society and that alternative
is austerity and from starting
predictions of a huge Tory majority at
the moment they may not admit for the
government because this election we gave
him something to vote for not just
something to focus against so my last
words environment before the election
were that represents a really important
nesting was the absolute privilege of my
I'm absolutely delighted by the ban to
continue to do that thank you very much